so my name is nathan totten i'm a
technical evangelist at microsoft i work
on uh windows azure
so uh probably a lot of stuff that most
of you have never heard of i see a lot
of macs in the room that's all right i
have a mac too so today i'm going to
talk about
cloud or node copters in the cloud so i
actually just got here today
unfortunately this is a super busy time
of the year for me so i wasn't able to
attend the full conference my
understanding is you guys saw a bunch of
robots drones things like that like 52
node copters so we're not going to go
over that again i know you've all seen
that but what we're going to do is talk
about
how we can do some some crazy stuff uh
with these uh node copters with the ar
drones connecting to the cloud
so um i want to preface this
this demo is like super crazy hardware
wise i brought my own router uh i have
this so they like there's two
possibilities of this it's either going
to be awesome and we're all going to
have fun or nothing's going to work and
i'm just going to sob up here so
hopefully that doesn't happen
so
anyway so uh again talking quickly so i
kind of already did the intro uh why are
we doing this so actually quick really
quick what we're going to show i'm going
to do mostly code
so what what i'm going to show here what
scenario i'm going to show is basically
we're going to build a local app
both running on my on my mac here but a
local app that's receiving messages from
the cloud and i'll explain a little bit
more how we're going to do that in a bit
and then we're going to build a
controller app that's going to send
messages so the idea is we could be
remote and actually fly this node copter
and we're going to use a queuing service
in the cloud in windows azure to
actually communicate between the two of
these so why are we doing this
well there's a couple reasons the first
one uh i really wanted to use my
corporate expense account to buy one of
these things so i had to think of a
reason to do so
the second reason i thought what would
be a fun what would be a really fun uh
way to uh to really just scare the the
crap out of my girlfriend um and i
thought if i just had this node copter
sitting in the living room and flew this
thing you know while i'm gone
that would that would be really fun for
me and probably get me in a lot of
trouble also pets it's super good on
pets so this is basically what we're
gonna build here uh we're gonna we're
gonna build a local app controlling our
through the cloud controlling our our
helicopter uh for the amusement of the
uh of the evil doer uh to scare the pets
and uh
the clip art folks in that uh in that
microsoft legal approved photo i'm
allowed to use so a really quick little
bit a sales pitch here so i do i do of
course work for microsoft uh they only
pay me if i tell you what i do
um
so again we're going to use windows
azure i'm going to make this 15 seconds
really quick we're going to skip the
marketing crap uh we're going to talk
about windows azure so how many people
have actually heard of windows azure
that is shocking okay how many people
have used it
okay cool so the only thing i'm really
going to say about windows azure is we
uh oh my there we go we uh we've really
done a lot for node.js we love node.js
so it's not all about microsoft right
it's not all about.net.net certainly
works super well if you do that i assume
no one in here does uh again judging by
the c of max there's a guy there's a guy
with an hp there don't be embarrassed so
i left mine in my hotel so i thought i'd
get lynched
so but uh yeah so basically we we've put
a lot of effort into uh into basically
making node.js work really well on
windows azure we actually have a number
of customers building very large
applications using a number of our
services on node.js running in windows
azure as i'll show today we have a whole
cli tools uh and and a whole sdk that
works entirely on mac i'm not using
windows so we are definitely not even
though it says windows it's all about
open source node.js
and other things so i would definitely
encourage you to try it out there's a
lot of like free if we've got all these
free programs like we like to give
things away for free um but there's like
a ton of stuff we give away for free
for windows azure like search for biz
spark or any number of things but
there's like a whole bunch of ways to
get a lot of free windows azure so
that's the only sales pitch i'll do i
apologize for that again i only get paid
if i uh if i say that
so windows azure dot com i'm actually
really happy that uh that that most of
you have heard about it it means our
i guess i'm doing a good job so uh for
the rest of the demo we're just gonna
code so this is the part that's either
gonna leave me uh weeping in tears or
everyone uh everyone clapping and
cheering in my head
fantasy
so
everyone seems very tired here
i've had like three red bulls this
morning i and there's three red bulls
out there why haven't you guys been
chugging these things anytime i'm given
free red bull i drink a lot of them it's
very dangerous um so i know like some
some of you may work at facebook i know
they're
they're they're red bulls there all the
time and uh and i think i would die if i
work there we only get free soda which
uh which makes it harder to ingest large
quantities of caffeine
so
let's zoom in on this a little bit
tell me if you can't see it so what i'm
going to show again is we're going to
really quickly in
18 minutes hopefully build an app
that we can use windows azure to
basically communicate from the client to
the cloud and make this thing fly and
probably crash
so uh let's give it a go so i have an
express.js app basically already set up
we uh we probably all know how to do
that i don't want to explain that i
would have time to explain that so i've
got a basic express js app i've got a
few modules installed the ar drone
module windows azure and then jade and
all that correct so
so let's do let's build our server side
app first so this is again just a raw a
raw express app so i'm going to build uh
sorry actually let's do our client-side
app first that makes more sense so what
i'm going to do is build a client-side
application that receives messages oh
i'm supposed to gesture to this monitor
that receives messages
from the cloud and tells our our drone
to fly to land
that's all i meant actually do because
otherwise i know i will crash it so fly
and land we've all seen the other things
it can do yes yesterday and then we're
also if we have time we're going to do
some stuff with some logging data um we
of course could do a lot more take
photos stream video all of the fun
things but but i think with we're pretty
short on time we won't have time to show
that so um
so i'm not actually going to code in
front of you but i do have some i've
cheated uh given the lack of time so the
first thing i want to do is is just use
our windows azure sdk uh to um to
actually read uh or sorry we're starting
with the client new file skipped a step
here so uh actually hang on i'm gonna
i'm gonna go even faster i'm gonna cheat
even more
apologize
since we're running short on time
all right so let's copy some code and
client.js
save that so we're basically we've uh
we're uh we've impor uh we've uh require
our ar drone module and uh and i have my
drone uh set on this ip address on my
own custom access point here so there's
a few things i'm gonna do
the first thing is i want to actually
i want to actually
receive some messages from the service
bus we'll send these messages in a
second but service bus is basically a
very simple queuing service in windows
azure so we're going to connect up to
this and we're just going to continually
pull windows azure service bus for
queues i excuse my code this is really
awful but this is this is just for demos
so that's why it's not very robust but
hopefully you'll forgive me let me zoom
in on that
and let me know if i'm talking too fast
again i have had three red bulls
so
i have a lot to get through in a very
short period of time
so so yeah so this is our code here what
we're doing is again we're
we're using the node.js sdk for windows
azure uh we're we're creating a service
bus q client and then we're going to
continually read from uh from the queue
and actually let's just uh set interval
and we'll do uh receive
oops
uh receive message
i can't spell i never can spell on stage
that's why i use snippets
all right receive
message and let's just do it so what
we're going to do is just set a set of
time set an interval here and we're
going to call our service bus every
second and check for a message and then
we're going to we're going to issue a
command so we need a few commands to
actually
to actually control our our drone uh and
these are things you guys have already
seen before i think uh
client so let's just do this really
quick commands so we've got a couple
commands here uh for takeoff and uh and
land uh so let's actually clock oops
client
uh
take off
no wait was it
yeah take off
that's why i called the takeoff so
client takeoff and client uh i don't
know why i didn't fill those client
lamps again can't spell on stage land
so
to recap this is our simple client and
this will be running on our local
machine i thought about actually running
this on a separate computer but there's
the issue of uh of um
two monitors i also thought like i could
run this on my surface on windows to
show that node works you know that we
could use both and then like to make it
even more portable like i could duct
tape my surface to the drone but then i
discovered that it wouldn't fly if it
had a computer
you guys don't like my humor come on are
you guys asleep was everyone out
drinking last night what's going on wake
up
i'm gonna be i'm gonna get louder unless
people start laughing i can't handle it
all right so
i'm trying let's have fun i want to have
fun all right
so i i know i know that most of the
sessions here are about learning
something useful again i'm going to
repeat this is only about
doing something completely ridiculous
and kind of having some fun with it so
let's try to have a little bit of fun so
we've got our service bus receiver we're
going to continually pull four messages
obviously these messages could be more
sophisticated i just have a string take
off land
we're not gonna do rotate because i've
had troubles with that in the past and
then we do all kinds of crazy things
then the thing's flying across the room
and someone gets hurt you know microsoft
lawsuit all kinds of stuff i get fired
so so we're gonna just do takeoff and
land up and down is safe but we could of
course do more sophisticated things pass
more data altitude things like that so
this is our client uh and we're going to
run that we're going to run this here in
just a second but let's build our server
so a couple code snippets here for
brevity
so
server service plus so we're going to
again connect to that same service bus
using our azure sdk service plus queue
and and we're going to we're going to
have we go to send command function here
and then i'm just going to add a few
routes we're going to do this again
really terribly with just some get
requests
routes
so we've got we've got our take off
route and we'll just redirect back to
home and our land gets and then let's
just add some very fancy ui i'm uh for
those who have seen me speak before
probably none of you
you will know that i'm world renowned
for my
great user interface abilities
there we go and that's that
yeah see someone's impressed
all right
so
so uh let's just make sure we got
everything so we have our client we've
got our cl we've got our server here
running express couple simple functions
sending some messages to the queue uh
command take off and land and then we've
got our client which should be running
locally receiving messages from the
queue and if all goes according to plan
uh we'll be able to do some fun stuff so
let's uh first let's run our
server
if i can type
why is my
node
what is happening
no there we go
app.js
all right we got that running and
client.js so again what
rookie mistake
you guys can shout at me
if i if you see something like you
missed a semicolon
or noob
all right
all right so we've got our we've got our
client js again remember even though
these are running on one machine these
in in practice when i'm harassing
friends relatives
family pets
would be running on two separate
machines and i would be
sitting somewhere remote
all right so let's go to our
let's go to our
unnamed browser here
there and get that they don't have
internet explorer on mac
i work for microsoft so i'm not allowed
to say the name i'm just kidding
so
i'm not really
oh that would be
i just get like a amount i get 100
deducted for my paycheck so that's fine
so so we've got our very fancy app up
here with our takeoff and our lan
command now hopefully this is still
connected and let's uh let's go ahead
and click take off and this is going to
enqueue a message
what do we do
oh
see there we go we got to save things
obviously
all right
now let's try that again
take off
yes
and it takes off and uh then
it worked so happy
and uh and we'll land and again uh
that's all we're gonna do i know there's
a lot more fun we can do but uh it will
it will fly around the room and it'll
crash and
bad things will happen so that's really
that's really the main the main thing i
want to show so this this to me like
even though again it's it's uh it's
pretty much useless uh but i think it's
a lot of fun and really like you can
imagine a lot of scenarios where
something like this would be useful
obviously there's the there's like a
bunch of industrial scenarios or remote
sensors remote devices
that you could actually build an app
like this
pushing messages from any network
through a service like windows azure
service bus cues and receiving that
locally um so the last thing i want how
much time do we have we have
we have oh sweet we've got enough time
so the next thing i want to show you is
so we've basically sent data using the
cloud now i want to use another another
service in windows azure this is a
simple uh storage service and actually
save some data up there um so let's so
the next thing we're just going to take
some of the telemetry data uh there's
for those who have again done node the
ar programming before uh it sends back
basically telemetry data like its
current altitude various rotation data
things like that um so what i want to do
is actually just read that data from the
node copter and actually save that up
into windows azure
uh so let's uh let's go back this will
do on our client application uh so let's
go ahead and just add some more code i
already have prepared here uh drone
blob
for this i'm going to
use our windows azure blob storage which
is uh which is basically just a a binary
service for storing any any binary data
we also have server we also have some
like table service for storing
schema-less tabular data we of course
have like sql in the cloud mysql various
things like that if you want to if you
want to use something with sql we have
through hosting providers we have of
course
mongodb things like that but this we're
just going to basically store a json
text object into our blob storage just
for simplicity
uh so we've got so again this is our our
save function connect to windows azure
blob storage and then create a blob and
save that
to let's create a new blob just so we
have an empty one to prove that it is
working so let's go back to so i'm just
going to go to my azure portal here and
uh storage
and cloud drone and let's just make a
new container i've already got some
logging data in there but so we have a
fresh one let's call this log 3
and we'll make a public container so
everyone can see all our fancy logging
data
log3 that's all right
and let's just change that to log three
so what we're going to do again on the
client we're going to receive data from
uh from our our copter as it's flying
and we're going to just save it back up
to win to the windows azure blob so we
can
look at it
that's really all that's all we have
just look at it uh so let's uh oh and we
need to uh
we need to fire an event client on
nav data so this is the uh the the the
uh the ar drone sdk is firing uh nav
data and um
uh
save
data save data
so uh if you notice i'm doing kind of
something silly here i'm only going to
save it like an arbitrarily every every
millisecond
that's
divisible by 100 just because basically
this event gets fired like like i don't
i don't know it's like forever but it
gets fired constantly um so like we end
up with a lot of data so i'm just kind
of like
limiting that to an arbitrary
arbitrarily smaller amount of data so
this is our this is all we need to do to
now capture data from our drone and save
it up into blob storage so let's go
ahead and uh and stop our
our clients here our client and run that
again
and now we are going to be capturing nav
data so let's uh let's let's launch this
again
and it's still working awesome
and
now let's go leave it running so we see
we're going to save some log data
and we'll land it now
awesome
it's less exciting the second time
and
now we should see that in in in our in
our
portal here we have we have got some
data so let's go ahead and copy the url
since we made this public we can just
browse this
and there we go we've got all our log
saved so uh so pretty simple uh we have
a few more minutes left um
so now so what i want to do i think we
have time
now i want to actually deploy this
application up into uh up in this the
web app up into windows azure so and
this is the part that gets very
dangerous so that you guys can decide
when it fly when it when it takes off
and lands um
so for node.js we have we have a service
called windows azure websites uh which
is basically a super easy way to
to deploy applications into the cloud so
let's just go ahead and create a windows
azure website and let's just call this
uh
jsconf
oh hey it's not taken cool beans
so let's choose our region east us and
create js jsconf so with windows azure
websites there's a variety of different
deployment options uh but the the one
that makes most sense for node
developers we can deploy right up to
windows azure websites with git so uh so
let's uh so our site's created and uh
let's go ahead and select this
and uh
go to our dashboard oops i've got our
dashboard go back and
set up deployment
so we can do a couple different things
we can actually deploy with continuous
integration from github or from you from
dropbox uh and from like bitbucket or
whatever or we can just push directly uh
to a to a local uh to a local git or to
a git endpoint just in our in our
deployment servers so we'll take just a
second uh to create that get endpoint
and then i'll uh then i'll i'll
initialize i'll set this up and
while this is
and here's our here's our git server so
let's just uh let's just quickly push
this up into uh windows azure so i'm
going to initialize this as a git repo
again just a regular git repo remote
azure oops
add azure
and i didn't put it ignore so we're
gonna push the node modules we don't
actually that's all right uh
we don't actually have to push up the
modules of course those will be
installed
uh the first time those will be
installed from uh packages um but i
forgot to create a pack an ignore uh the
git ignore file so we're just gonna push
those up anyway which is fine git push
azure master although it'll take a
little longer so it'll make it quite
cool but that's all right
so again we're just pushing this uh this
website up to
up to uh
up to windows azure websites yeah port
good
so we're just pushing this up with git
to windows azure websites uh to a
website that will be at
jsconf.azurewebsites.net
and i should not have committed the
modules because they're huge compared to
the site but that's all right so
normally you would obviously ignore the
modules and not commit that into your
git repo as would be best practice and
windows azure websites will pull those
and install those
when you when you push the site so
making it much faster
so we'll see here our deployment happens
and this just takes a few seconds
a few seconds longer
it always takes longer when you're
demoing right
anyway any questions while we're waiting
oh there we go no questions
all right
jsconf.azurewebsites.net uh so yeah good
question so do native modules work so
yes uh so windows azure websites is
running on windows uh we are microsoft
after all um so we do support uh running
linux in windows azure through virtual
machines are websites which is basically
a a high higher level purely managed
hosting environment does run windows so
basically any module i mean most nade
module and most native modules at this
point do run i mean do work on windows
there are certainly a number that don't
though
if they don't build on windows they're
not going to work on windows azure
websites uh we're working we're working
we want to fix that like oh my god i
forgot that i forgot that this
oh man see this is why i only made it
take off and landing otherwise like you
guys would be flying around the room and
there would be a lawsuit and it would be
it would be bad i would definitely get
fired so cool yeah so this is uh this is
my demo hopefully this this uh this was
fun and now hopefully uh some of you i'm
not actually recommending this but
hopefully you can use it for some sort
of uh entertaining purposes scaring
friends and family and pets
not pets so that that would i was a joke
that would actually be mean i wouldn't
do that but friends and family of course
so uh yes so so yeah so back to the uh
the node modules yeah so we're working
on it um i don't know what the solution
will be whether we have build servers
that are linux whether we eventually
have like linux servers for uh for node
but yeah there is a limitation with that
right now
cool and you guys are fighting over it
now i like it
all right
so all right we're just out of time so
uh hopefully that was somewhat enjoyable
and maybe a little useful but like i
said there so for uh for windows azure
if you are a startup or if you're
building something and you want free
hosting just go to microsoft.comwac
bizspark we've got this program that
basically we're going to give you like
it's like six thousand dollars a year of
free windows azure to host uh your stuff
on so a shameless plug but you get a lot
of free stuff so i would definitely urge
you to check that out if you do happen
to have an msdn subscription already
through work or whatever you also get a
ton of free windows azure through that
so uh thank you very much hopefully this
was enjoyable and enjoy the rest of the
day
you